slop banging in your face when your time
goes running I'm the tur in the race
back keep on coming back keep on coming
Su going straight when your time goes
running when your time goes
[Music]
running when your time goes running when
your time goes running
w got fing in your face when your time
goes running I'm the turtle in the race
you better keep on coming better keep on
coming no shut Mo not going straight
stop fing in your face when your time
goes running I'm the turt in the race
you better keep on coming better keep on
coming the something is not going
straight oh safe staying out on cold
it's a shame you gr your own lay Scar
the friends you've been
sold Wast it on your
own it's a strange
world I can't walk
out of what I want
to so obsessed thinking
about what they could do if your head
love it's only full of regrets and not
shame you on your
wrong it's a strange
world I can't walk
out I want to stop fing in your face
when your time go running I'm the turtle
in the race you better keep on coming
better keep on I'm coming the going
straight stoping in your face when you
time in the race you better keep on
coming better keep on
coming going
strange it's a strange
world I can't walk
out but I want
to
it's their thing not yours I will put
you in a headlock not your using
popularity to get it you think that want
it but you it the face F
you and go on just control
yourself I go with them
now you don't deserve this life to
live and go on just control
yourself but don't let them
in you don't deserve this like
today stop finding in your face when you
time in the race you better keep better
keeping